En pleine Corée du Nord,
Un groupe de touristes français vient d'arriver.
Nous nous sommes glissés parmi eux.
Nous arrivons bientôt dans notre hôtel.
Il est déjà 22h,
Alors que tous les touristes vont se coucher.
Nous tentons d'aller
visiter la ville de nuit.
Derrière nous, un homme inquiet arrive en courant.
C'est le portier.
Nous devons rentrer,
Car il est formellement interdit
de sortir sans guide officiel.
Nous insistons quand même.
Stop ! Stop !
Impossible de s'échapper.
Nous avons perdu notre liberté,
il faut obéir.
À l'intérieur, les deux dictateurs nord coréens,
le père et le fils, trônent dans le hall.
Monsieur Jan travaille pour l'État,
c'est lui le guide officiel.
Il escorte les Français et il a tout vu.
Je voulais aller me promener en ville,
et ils on dit non.
On ne peut pas se promener en ville ?
Parce que tout le monde
sait que tu es un espion.
Allez, on va manger ?
Tu sais, on a déjà arrêté
des espions tout près d'ici.
Ici, tout étranger est un espion potentiel.
Bienvenue en Corée du Nord.
Le pays le plus fermé au monde.
Le symbole de ce qui se fait
de pire en matière de dictature.
Ce pays vit sur une autre planète
depuis sa création en 1953,
Après la guerre contre la Corée du Sud.
Elle vit surtout dans une paranoïa aiguë
et une misère absolue.
Aucun chiffre ne circule sur l'économie locale,
Mais on sait que des famines
frappent régulièrement la population.
À la fin des années 90,
Plus d'un million de Nord-Coréens
seraient morts de faim.
Encore aujourd'hui, selon l'ONU,
20% de la population
ne trouve pas de nourriture.
Les famines se multiplient dans les campagnes,
Et c'est pour cela que le Programme alimentaire mondial,
Distribue près de 400 000 tonnes
de denrées alimentaires chaque année.
Car l'agriculture locale,
Faute de machines et même d'animaux,
reste proche du néant.
Il faut donc se nourrir de ce que l'on trouve,
Des algues, des racines, moins que le minimum.
Officiellement, le pays est dirigé par Kim Il-sung.
Cet homme, représenté dans tout le pays
sous forme de statues monumentales,
De fresques et d'affiches,
Est en effet le président éternel
de la Corée du Nord.
Mais cet homme est mort en 1994.
Son fils, Kim Jong-il, lui a succédé,
Et continue d'enfermer le pays
dans le même délire suicidaire.
Et cela grâce à une armée toujours plus nombreuse.
On parle de plus d'un million de soldats.
Une armée toujours en guerre contre la Corée du Sud,
Suréquipée et qui dispose même de l'arme atomique.
Kim Jong-il peut ainsi continuer l'œuvre
de destruction de son père.
Résultat,
On continue de vivre ici
comme dans l'U.R.S.S des années 30.
Les mêmes files d'attente pour
les rares bus qui ont de l'essence.
Les mêmes magasins vides dans
lesquels il est interdit de filmer.
Le peuple n'y va jamais.
Mais il existe aussi des autoroutes.
Par contre, elles ne sont empruntées que
par des vélos et des piétons,
Obligés de nettoyer les flaques d'eau sur le bitume.
Il y a aussi, un casino dans la capitale
où on peut s'amuser avec des machines à sous.
Sauf qu'il n'y a rien à gagner.
Les pièces ne permettent que de rejouer.
On peut aussi s'entraîner au golf,
Sport ô combien capitaliste,
Sauf que seule l'élite du régime y a accès.
Pour les 23 millions de Nord-Coréens,
les temps sont durs,
Mais il faut sourire, c'est obligatoire.
Les moments de joie sont organisés,
même dans les rues,
Et forcément grandiose.
C'est cet univers angoissant,
Où tout un peuple est conditionné dès la naissance,
Qu'un groupe de Français a décidé
de passer ses vacances.
À 8 500€ pour trois semaines,
C'est un séjour aussi cher qu'aux Seychelles.
Mais là, pas de luxe, pas de cocotiers,
Seulement des guides austères et menaçants
qui vérifient chaque photo.
Des chambres sans matelas et sans eau courante.
En plus il y a des couvertures dedans.
Regardez.
C'est bien ?
C'est bon, pour moi c'est parfait !
Et bien sûr, des caméras pour
vous surveiller en permanence.
La Corée du Nord, une version totalitaire du paradis.
L'organisateur de ce petit voyage de rêve,
C'est cet homme aux cheveux blonds,
Guillaume de Vaudrey.
Il a une spécialité,
Les vacances dans les pires
endroits de la planète.
Dans son groupe, il y a Claude.
Pour cette jeune retraitée,
Ce séjour est le plus important de toute sa vie.
Car elle va enfin pouvoir retourner
sur les traces de son père,
Originaire de Corée du Nord.
Jacqueline n'a pas hésité une seconde,
À accompagner Claude, son amie.
Elle se définit comme une ancienne trotskiste,
Et va découvrir pour la première fois,
Ce qu'est une vraie dictature.
Il y a également Henri.
Il a choisi de garder l'anonymat.
Ce retraité, les dictatures, ça le connaît.
Il est déjà allé en Iran et il a adoré.
À son tableau de chasse,
il lui manquait la Corée du Nord,
Et c'est maintenant chose faite.
Nous serons escortés et surveillés
par des guides francophones.
Avec les lunettes Monsieur Hô
et à droite, Monsieur Jan.
Ensemble, c'est parti pour 3 semaines de propagande.
Pyongyang, la DMZ,
La ligne de démarcation entre les deux pays.
Puis l'extrême nord et
les côtes de la mer du Japon.
Un périple exceptionnel,
Encore jamais réalisé par
des étrangers occidentaux.
Pour commencer notre visite
au pays du bonheur socialiste,
Nous sommes invités à partager
un grand moment de joie,
Avec le peuple nord coréen.
Et quoi de plus approprié,
Qu'un gigantesque Luna Park,
le seul du pays.
Ici, tout le monde sourit.
Des petits gestes de bienvenue,
Mettent tout de suite à l'aise les visiteurs étrangers.
Au programme, des attractions d'une autre époque.
Tir à l'arc,
Jeu d'adresse avec des ballons
aussi vieux que les joueurs,
Des balançoires à l'ancienne,
Ou encore des fusées munies de leur mitrailleuse
prise d'assaut par des adultes,
Sous le regard du surveillant en chef du manège.
Évidemment, les infrastructures datent un peu,
Et la sécurité semble douteuse.
Il y a aussi le clou du spectacle,
Les montagnes russes,
Mais elles sont fermées
depuis déjà plusieurs années.
Ce n'est pas grave, il en faut plus
pour gâcher le plaisir des Français,
Qui embarquent dans la grande roue.
À l'intérieur,
Une joie généralisée et communicative.
C'est malin, on continue de monter !
On est à la moitié.
Ça va aller toi ?
Là, on est arrêté.
Je crois qu'on est en panne.
Là haut, c'est le télésiège.
C'est calme, il n'y a pas de sono abrutissant.
Maintenant dans les foires ou dans les fêtes foraines,
il y a des sonos.
Henri semble conquis par l'ambiance bon enfant
et le calme du parc.
Même Monsieur Hô, l'un des guides,
baigne dans le bonheur et veut l'immortaliser.
Moi, je filme la joie
du parc d'attractions.
Au stand de barbe à papa, ça se bouscule.
On tend des billets pour son acheter,
De l'argent pour les enfants
et même des jeunes rappeurs.
C'est donc cela la Corée du Nord ?
Le pire régime communiste de la planète ?
Il y a de la racaille,
Les racailles de banlieue qui débarquent.
Absolument incroyable !
Et si les gens font la queue ici,
ce n'est pas pour manger,
Mais juste pour faire un tour d'auto-tamponneuses.
Mais très vite,
La réalité de la Corée du Nord refait surface.
Un groupe de militaires en goguette apparaît,
Le ton change.
Attention, voilà des militaires.
On ne prend pas de photos.
Que viennent donc faire ici ces soldats ?
Pour en savoir plus, nous les suivons
jusqu'à un stand un peu spécial.
Monsieur Jan, qu'est-ce qu'il y a écrit là ?
A bas les impérialistes !
A bas les agresseurs américains !
Mais pourquoi il y a cette haine encore ?
C'est fini la Guerre.
Pendant longtemps, les Américains ont occupé notre pays.
La paix n'est toujours pas
signée de toutes façons,
C'est toujours un
cessez-le-feu seulement.
Les Américains ont
déclenché la guerre,
Notre nation a
beaucoup souffert.
Pour l'instant, ces bidasses tirent
avec des jouets sur des soldats de plomb.
Mais ils sont prêts à en découdre pour de vrai.
Cette guerre,
La Corée du Nord s'y prépare
depuis près de 60 ans,
Depuis sa création.
Et l'ennemi absolu,
ce sont les Etats-Unis.
1950, le monde sort péniblement
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
D'un côté, le bloc communiste,
De l'autre, les pro-américains.
La Corée se retrouve au cœur
de ce conflit idéologique,
Et sombre dans une guerre qui durera 3 ans.
Ceux du Sud reçoivent le soutien des Américains,
Et ceux du Nord sont aidés par la Chine.
En 1953, la Corée est officiellement
divisée en deux.
Encore aujourd'hui, aucun traité de paix n'a été validé.
De fait, les 2 Corées sont toujours en guerre.
Les vacanciers vont vite comprendre.
Les Français ont droit à une visite
sur la zone qui sépare les deux pays.
Donc ici, vous entrez dans les 2km
démilitarisés du côté nord,
Qui sont cultivés par les paysans.
Et à droite, vous voyez le drapeau
de la République de Corée.
Juste de l'autre côté,
À quelques mètres à peine,
c'est la partie adverse.
Les traîtres de Corée du Sud.
Pour aller plus loin,
Il faut se mettre en file indienne,
Et passer un par un sous le regard
vigilant des soldats.
L'ambiance est tendue et il est interdit
de prendre des photos.
Nous sommes ici dans la zone
la plus sensible au monde.
Tout autour, ce sont près
d'un million de soldats des 2 camps,
Qui sont prêts à en découdre.
Le petit groupe arrive enfin
sur la ligne de démarcation,
La fameuse DMZ.
L'instant est solennel.
De chaque côté de la frontière
que nous avons représenté en rouge,
Des gardes.
Aucun ne se regarde,
mais tous sont aux aguets.
Le premier, qui met un pied de l'autre côté,
Est immédiatement repéré par
cette flopée de caméras,
Et abattu sur le champ.
Les tenues des soldats
sont complètement différentes.
Style rétro, du côté nord coréen,
Ray-Ban et équipement à l'américaine
chez les autres.
Les Américains possèdent
le commandement militaire.
Dans la zone sud coréenne,
Une délégation de généraux américains débarque.
Ils vont même se faire prendre en photo
avec la Corée du Nord derrière eux.
C'est tout ce qu'ils pourront voir
du pays communiste.
Pour les Français, c'est le moment de partir.
Mais avant,
Claude tient à laisser un témoignage
sur le livre d'or des visiteurs.
C'est un moment très important
pour cette Française,
Née d'un père coréen et d'une mère française.
Et si Claude a fait ce voyage,
c'est en mémoire de son père.
90 ans après que mon père ait dû quitter
son pays occupé par les Japonais,
Je viens sur cette ligne de
démarcation qui partage la Corée.
Ce partage a toujours été la grande peine de mon père,
Qui n'a jamais revu sa terre natale.
Le père de Claude,
avait fui la Corée en 1920,
Bien avant l'arrivée du régime communiste.
C'est lui, sur cette photo d'époque,
Juste avant qu'il ne trouve refuge en France,
Il ne pourra jamais revenir
dans son pays de naissance.
Cet instant d'émotion ne fait toutefois
pas oublier aux touristes,
Qu'ils sont dans un pays où tout est contrôlé.
Au même moment, les soldats et les guides
demandent à voir les clichés,
Qui viennent d'être pris sur la frontière.
Une bonne partie sera effacée.
Pour le petit groupe de français,
cette surveillance pointilleuse,
Est juste une habitude à prendre.
Et pour l'instant, personne n'y trouve rien à redire.
La visite peut continuer,
Selon le programme concocté
par les autorités nord coréennes.
Un programme qui ne laisse rien au hasard.
Place donc, au musée de la Guerre.
Au fond de la cour,
une vieille dame nettoie des cailloux.
Tout d'un coup, une assistante des guides,
Arrive et s'empresse de la faire disparaître.
Elle faisait tache dans le paysage.
Une tache de pauvreté
qu'il faut cacher aux étrangers.
Car c'est l'image même du pays qui est en jeu.
Une image de perfection qui va continuer
avec cette jeune militaire.
Bonjour, soyez les bienvenus
à notre musée.
Derrière elle, une fresque gigantesque,
Comme il se doit à la gloire de Kim Il-sung,
Le créateur de la Corée du Nord.
Ici, il est l'égal d'un dieu.
Et toute l'histoire récente du pays a été
réécrite pour lui et par lui.
Nous avons fait un film,
Asseyez-vous, s'il vous plaît.
Sur le problème coréen, sur la guerre coréenne.
Et ça va vous aider à bien
comprendre le problème coréen.
C'est donc une version plutôt partisane
du conflit contre les Etats-Unis,
Qui va être servie aux visiteurs.
Une version où les Américains
tiennent forcément le mauvais rôle.
La voix, le style des images, tout y est.
On se croirait dans un mauvais film
de propagande des années 50.
Qui a donc déclenché la guerre en Corée ?
Voici les séquences qui donnent la réponse.
Ecoutez bien, comment en Corée du Nord,
on réécrit l'histoire.
La Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
A permis aux Américains de tirer de gros profits,
Grâce à la vente massive des matériels de guerre.
Mais après cette guerre,
Les Etats-Unis ont perdu leurs débouchés d'armes
et de matériel de guerre qu'ils avaient fabriqué.
Ils ont dû subir une crise économique catastrophique.
Ils ont donc prôné qu'il faut déclencher,
Au plus vite possible,
La guerre de Corée pour s'en sortir.
Et ils se sont livrés frénétiquement
aux préparatifs de guerre.
Tout est faux.
Les États-Unis n'ont jamais été aussi
prospères qu'après la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Mais ce n'est pas grave.
Le documentaire continue sa démonstration
sur le même ton.
Truman, le président américain,
A prôné dans son message,
Présenté au Congrès en 1945,
Qu'il faut déclencher une guerre en Corée,
Pour que les Américains puissent dominer le monde.
C'est même l'exact contraire.
Les historiens s'accordent à dire que
c'est la Corée du Nord qui a déclenché la guerre.
Une réalité que le régime de Pyongyang
nie de toutes ses forces.
Et en parfaite dictature,
enseigne à tous les enfants du pays,
Dès leur plus jeune âge.
Les Français n'en reviennent pas,
mais n'osent rien dire.
Pas un ne réagit.
Docilement, ils vont continuer la visite,
Et ils ne sont pas au bout de leurs surprises.
Ils traversent au pas de charge,
Les salles remplies de photos
et de posters guerriers.
La réécriture de l'histoire continue.
Les américains ont fait pénétrer
des avions en mer de Chine,
Pour bombarder
des villes et des villages,
Et massacrer le peuple chinois.
Les Américains qui massacrent le peuple chinois,
Henri n'en a jamais entendu parler.
Il prend son courage à deux mains et se lance.
-Il faut que je pose une question...
-Vas-y Henri.
C'était en quelle année à peu près, cet épisode ?
En quelle année à peu près ?
Cette bataille ?
-Oui.
C'est pendant la guerre.
De 1950 à 1953.
Oui, d'accord,
c'est un ensemble de batailles...
La réponse est vaseuse et prend Henri de cours,
Mais il n'ose aller plus loin
et se fait taquiner par notre journaliste.
T'as pas lancé la question.
T'es vraiment un dégonflé.
J'ai pas assez de force.
La Corée du Nord est un État totalitaire,
Qui fait même peur aux étrangers.
Ici, il n'y a aucune relation
diplomatique avec la France.
En cas de problème,
Personne ne peut venir
vous libérer ou faire pression.
La jeune femme nous attend dans une autre salle.
À l'intérieur, des navires et des avions
à taille réelle.
La leçon de propagande continue de plus belle.
Ici, c'est la salle des armes.
Ils ont exposés des armes originales,
Qui ont obtenu des mérites,
Au cours de la guerre.
Alors que la jeune soldate récite sa leçon,
Nous allons oser poser une question sensible.
Ils ont fait couler le croiseur lourd américain
qui s'appelle Baltimore,
Avec quatre torpilleurs,
Et ce torpilleur numéro 21,
Était le commandant torpilleur
dans cette opération.
C'est celui que vous avez utilisé récemment
pour couler le bateau sud coréen ?
Il y a un bateau sud coréen qui a coulé.
J'entends ça pour la première fois.
C'est la première fois
qu'on entend ça.
Il y a seulement quelques semaines,
Un navire de guerre sud coréen a été
coulé près des côtes de Pyongyang.
À bord, 46 marins ont été tués.
Et au moment de la visite des Français,
la tension entre les deux pays,
Est à son niveau maximal.
Suite à notre question, hors caméras,
Nous serons convoqués plusieurs heures
par des agents nord coréens,
Qui nous conseilleront de ne plus poser
ce type de questions à l'avenir,
Sous peine de devoir prolonger,
De quelques mois, voire quelques années,
notre séjour ici.
Mais pour l'instant,
Tout continue comme si de rien n'était.
La guide du musée enchaîne son petit tour,
Mais la gêne est palpable.
Elle présente fièrement un vieux chasseur
de l'armée de l'air.
Cet avion s'appelle le MIG.
Il a été visité par le camarade
Kim Il Sung en 1952.
Depuis 1952, ce type d'avions, un MiG 15,
Est toujours en service en Corée du Nord,
Comme on le voit sur ces images volées
sur l'un des aéroports.
Une armée vieillissante qu'il ne faut
pas prendre à la légère,
Comme le démontre cette dernière salle.
À partir d'ici ce sont des armes prises à l'ennemi,
Ce sont des trophées.
Toutes ces armes ont tué.
Il y a de tout.
Fusils mitrailleurs, casques, drapeaux,
Des chars ou encore des hélicoptères.
Une vraie caverne d'Ali Baba d'un goût macabre.
Et une nouvelle occasion
d'en remettre une couche,
Sur la culpabilité des méchants Américains.
Ils ont utilisé des armes
chimiques et bactériologiques,
Pendant la guerre.
Et ce bâtiment a été abattu,
Au moment du largage d'une bombe bactériologique.
Vrai ou faux ?
Impossible de faire le tri
dans cette propagande grossière.
Avant de quitter le musée,
Le clou de la visite,
Une gigantesque fresque murale sur la bataille de Séoul.
Évidemment,
Le beau rôle revient aux héroïques
soldats communistes,
Qui ont sauvé le régime nord coréen,
Et continuent aujourd'hui de le maintenir vivant.
Nos touristes,
Commencent à comprendre
où ils ont mis les pieds.
Fatigués, ils rentrent à leur hôtel.
C'est l'heure de pointe.
Les gens sont surpris de croiser un véhicule.
Tout le monde rentre du travail,
Et se regroupent sagement
pour attendre les bus.
C'est la queue
pour aller au stade ça ?
Non, c'est pour le bus.
À gauche, ce grand bâtiment,
C'est le Palais du peuple.
Nous sommes ici sur
les Champs Elysées locaux,
À l'heure de pointe.
Les rares bus sont bondés et
sur le point de rendre l'âme.
Et sur le bord des routes,
Aucune publicité,
mais des affiches géantes de propagande,
Pour le régime communiste.
On y voit des hommes fiers de construire
le futur d'un pays idéal.
Un pays où les femmes sont là
pour élever les enfants.
Ces deux tours à droite,
c'est leur hôtel,
L'un des plus luxueux du pays.
À l'intérieur,
Un restaurant, mais surtout une télé,
Tout le temps allumée sur la chaîne nationale.
Au menu chants patriotiques,
Devant un parterre de militaires,
Discours de généraux.
Bien sûr, des images de vacances,
Du dictateur national Kim Jong-il.
Et un documentaire sur
la meilleure façon d'utiliser,
Une kalachnikov.
Au moment de rejoindre sa chambre,
Jacqueline découvre avec angoisse
qu'elle ne peut pas envoyer elle-même,
Dix mails à sa famille.
Tout est contrôlé par l'État,
Et elle doit obligatoirement
donner l'adresse du destinataire,
À un fonctionnaire local.
J'ai aucune adresse,
J'en ai eu une, pardon,
mais j'ai pas de répertoire.
Ce n'est pas grave.
Avant, c'était comme ça.
Moi j'ai bien dit aux gens,
Pas de nouvelles, bonnes nouvelles.
Henri, lui, ne trouve rien à redire
à ces nouvelles règles contraignantes.
Le pays est coupé du monde.
Le lendemain, Pyongyang se réveille,
Dans une ambiance surréaliste.
Cette musique que l'on entend en fond sonore,
Est diffusée dès l'aube dans toute la ville.
Il n'est pas encore 6h du matin.
Le ciel reste obscurci par les volutes opaques
des hauts fourneaux des usines.
Déjà, de petites mains s'activent
pour astiquer les rues encore désertes.
Une femme fait la circulation dans le vide,
Comme une marionnette devenue folle.
Tout doit être parfait
dans la capitale du régime communiste.
Mais il en faut plus pour
cacher l'extrême pauvreté du pays.
Entre deux rangées d'immeubles,
On découvre un curieux manège.
Ce camion, c'est une fosse septique sur roues.
À deux pas de là,
Un groupe d'hommes,
Le crâne rasé, habillés à l'identique,
militaires ou fonctionnaires,
Ils pratiquent leur gymnastique matinale en cadence.
C'est cela la Corée du Nord.
Une machinerie folle, qui dure depuis 60 ans.
Ce pays où la religion
est strictement interdite,
A un dieu, il s'appelle Kim Il-Sung,
Le Staline local.
C'est lui qui a créé et dirigé le pays
de 1953 à sa mort en 1994.
Il est partout dans le pays,
Sous forme de statues, de photos, de fresques.
Plus fort que le président à vie,
Il s'est désigné président éternel.
Et comme tout le monde dans le pays,
notre groupe de Français,
Va devoir lui rendre hommage.
Ça commence par l'achat de bouquets de fleurs.
À déposer devant
la statue de Kim Il-Sung.
Puis il faut s'approcher
de la statue du grand leader.
On ne peut pas la louper.
Elle fait plus de 15 mètres de haut.
Tout en bronze et entourée
d'une fresque à sa gloire.
Le protocole est très précis,
On ne fait pas n'importe quoi
devant Kim Il-Sung.
Voilà, on s'arrête.
Guillaume prend les choses en main.
On va d'abord offrir les fleurs,
On revient à la place.
Alors, allez déjà déposer les bouquets.
Tous les trois.
On revient, on revient à la place.
Revenez.
Comme un seul homme, on se met en alignement.
On va compter jusqu'à 3.
À 3, tout le monde s'incline.
Combien de fois ?
Une seule fois, quand même.
Un, deux, trois.
Rendre hommage à l'un des plus grands
dictateurs de la planète.
C'est une étape obligatoire
pour ces vacances un peu spéciales.
Moi j'adore !
Le fait de saluer ?
Ah oui, c'est impressionnant ça.
Ok bon, les asiatiques saluent beaucoup.
Même pour se dire bonjour.
Partout en Asie, on salue.
Et si en France, on devait aller saluer
la présidence de la République,
Ça ferait quel effet ?
Moi, je n'irai pas.
Je n'aime pas le
culte de la personnalité.
Non. Peut-être Carla.
Derrière les Français, le petit manège continue.
Un autre groupe de Coréens arrive à son tour
pour ce pèlerinage obligatoire.
Un salut parfait.
Puis c'est au tour des balayeurs,
De faire place nette
pour mieux accueillir les suivants.
Et c'est ainsi toutes les heures,
tous les jours de la semaine.
Pour l'instant, le séjour des touristes
se passe parfaitement.
Les guides nord coréens parviennent,
À montrer leur pays sous un meilleur jour.
Bien loin de l'image de dictature
à bout de souffle,
Que l'on a habituellement.
La petite visite de ce
paradis communiste se poursuit donc.
Prochaine étape,
La pizzeria, l'unique pizzeria du pays.
Un privilège réservé à l'élite
et aux rares étrangers.
Ce restaurant n'existe pas par hasard,
Mais sur ordre direct de Kim Jong-il,
Le dictateur nord coréen.
Tout simplement parce qu'il adore les pizzas.
Et évidemment, comme dans toute zone sensible,
interdit de filmer.
Tout est parti d'abord de sa volonté
de manger de la cuisine italienne,
Qu'il apprécie beaucoup.
Et puis ensuite, il a fait venir ici,
Pendant quelques années,
Des cuisiniers italiens de Naples,
Et il s'est dit pourquoi pas former
un cuisinier coréen en Italie.
Donc le cuisinier est parti quelque temps se former,
Et l'expert italien est venu tester les cuisiniers.
Au début, le cuisinier italien disait :
"Non, c'est pas parfait."
On a recommencé jusqu'à trouver
la recette la plus parfaite.
C'est donc le seul pizzaiolo Nord-Coréen
qui va préparer le dîner des Français.
Dans les cuisines,
Le personnel fait chauffer les fours
entre deux pannes de courant.
Le petit chouchou du dictateur, c'est lui,
L'un des rares Nord-Coréens à avoir eu
le droit de sortir du pays.
Il y a deux ans,
Je suis allé à Rome, en Italie,
Pour apprendre à faire des pizzas.
Il faut compter dans les 5€
pour une pizza jambon fromage.
Guillaume rappelle que dans ce pays de famine,
Ce n'est pas tous les jours que l'on mange aussi bien.
Vous savez, c'est l'unique occasion
où vous mangerez du fromage.
Donc, profitez-en.
Au moment de payer, on a le choix.
Dollar ou euro,
Mais pas en monnaie locale
qui est interdite aux étrangers.
La Corée du Nord commencerait donc
à s'ouvrir sur le monde.
Et pas uniquement pour former des pizzaïolos.
Les gens ont le droit de s'amuser un peu.
Des bateaux sur le fleuve, Taedong,
Des animaux de compagnie, comme ce petit chien.
Les jeunes font du roller
sur la place du peuple.
Et il n'est plus exceptionnel
d'avoir des téléphones portables.
Mais uniquement pour des appels locaux.
Il existe même des endroits où le peuple
a le droit de prendre du bon temps,
Bowling, billard américain,
Autant d'indices d'un léger
relâchement du régime,
Et surtout de l'influence
des produits de consommation,
De l'allié chinois.
Ces bouleversements, nos touristes
ne se rendent pas compte.
Ce qu'ils cherchent, c'est du traditionnel.
Et pour ramener des souvenirs typiques,
Quoi de mieux que l'institut de broderies de Pyongyang.
Mais à peine arrivé,
Une mauvaise nouvelle.
Les brodeuses sont invisibles et le resteront.
On va se faire rembourser.
On ne peut pas voir une ou deux brodeuses au travail ?
Au travail, juste une ou deux ?
Est-ce qu'il y a dans ce musée
des pièces de broderie anciennes ?
Oui.
Les fameuses broderies anciennes, les voici,
deux petits chatons dans le noir,
On y voit rien.
Même avec un briquet, il est impossible
de profiter des œuvres.
Dans les escaliers,
Un employé arrive enfin avec une lampe torche.
Mais ça ne servira à rien,
Il faut rapprocher les pièces
de la lumière du jour pour en profiter.
C'est très joli.
150€.
150€, Monsieur Hô ne perd pas le nord,
Le guide tente quand même une petite vente.
Ça m'énerve.
Qu'est-ce qui t'énerve ?
Ça m'énerve parce que
ces gens ne savent pas vivre.
Ils ne se rendent pas compte.
Ils sont tous résignés,
c'est ce qui m'énerve.
Ça peut durer encore des années.
La jeune retraitée semble
oublier où elle est.
Dans une dictature totale,
Où il est impossible de se révolter.
Le jugement des touristes est sans appel.
Bon, c'est décevant.
On n'a pas du tout vu de pièces anciennes, aucune.
Il n'y a pas de vêtement...
Leur expliquer que s'ils veulent vendre des trucs,
Ils ont qu'à les allumer.
Ça me pompe l'air.
Ils sont tellement enfermés
dans leur truc.
Enfin, avec Internet,
La radio, la télé,
Moi je me demande quand même,
Comment ils peuvent continuer longtemps à penser ça.
Jacqueline ne réalise pas qu'ici,
on ne vit pas comme chez nous.
Aucune information n'est libre.
Tout est filtré et contrôlé
par le régime totalitaire.
Internet est même totalement interdit.
À la bibliothèque centrale de Pyongyang,
Les ordinateurs ne manquent pas.
Sont-ils connectés sur Internet ?
Un petit essai sur Google
nous permet vite de vérifier.
Aucune réponse à notre requête.
Rien.
Le pays n'a pas de réseau.
Les autorités ne le permettent pas.
Elles veulent contrôler
les esprits de ses citoyens.
Et ça, dès le plus jeune âge.
Dans les rues, c'est bien avant 6 ans,
Que les enfants apprennent à défiler au pas,
En scandant des chants patriotiques
à la gloire du grand leader Kim.
À quelques rues de là, un jardin d'enfants.
Ceux-là ne chante pas,
Mais s'amusent sur des toboggans
et d'autres jeux en parfait état.
De nouveau l'image du bonheur,
en quelque sorte.
Henri, qui vient d'avoir
une petite discussion avec le guide,
Est sous le charme.
Il m'a dit c'est pas comme en France,
Vous ne verrez pas de SDF dans les cartons.
Il n'y a pas d'enfants qui se droguent,
Les enfants respectent les professeurs.
Et c'est vrai. Voilà.
En fait, la pauvreté est soigneusement
dissimulée aux yeux des étrangers.
Et quasi impossible à filmer.
En revanche, les écoles modèles,
comme ici,
On nous les présente sans aucun problème.
À l'intérieur,
Les enfants sont évidemment
beaux, polis et en permanence souriants.
Dans cette salle, on apprend à reconnaître
les arbres fruitiers du pays.
Un peu plus loin,
une collection d'animaux empaillés.
En fait, c'est toute la faune locale qui est ici.
Quoi de mieux pour apprendre
aux enfants à les reconnaître ?
Petite démonstration devant des Français conquis.
La directrice, imperturbable,
continue la visite.
L'accueil des enfants est chaleureux,
À défaut d'être spontané.
Dans cette pièce, les petits de 5 ans,
Apprennent les principaux épisodes
de la vie de Kim Il-Sung.
Et quand ils les récitent,
ils y mettent tout leur cœur.
*
À l'aide d'une vidéo, la maîtresse
en remet une petite couche.
Le Président éternel peut-être
fier de ses petits écoliers.
Avec eux, l'avenir socialiste du pays est garanti,
Et quand ils récitent,
ils y mettent tout leur cœur.
Claude,
Qui a été enseignant toute sa vie,
n'en revient pas.
Et commence sérieusement à être mal à l'aise.
Ils apprennent par cœur.
On leur apprend quoi ?
Tout ce qui concerne l'histoire,
Du président et du grand dirigeant.
On commence déjà à 3 ans,
À leur apprendre le lieu,
à leur montrer la maison,
À répéter, ça, c'est cet endroit là,
Ça c'est cet endroit là... Et voilà.
Comme ça, c'est bien encré.
Comme moi ma première
récitation, je la sais encore.
Claude fait attention à ce qu'elle dit
car le guide n'est jamais très loin.
Dans cette salle, des lits pour enfants,
les lits du pensionnat.
Car dès 5 ans,
Ils passent toute la semaine ici,
sans jamais rentrer chez eux.
L'Etat se substitue au rôle des parents.
Un peu plus loin, d'autres enfants jouent,
dansent et chantent,
Au milieu de jouets splendides.
Les références militaires restent omniprésentes,
Comme ces avions de chasse,
Ou certains enfants sont déguisés
en officiers de l'armée.
Et d'autres embarquent dans
un train électrique géant.
C'est mieux que dans n'importe
quelle école occidentale.
Tant de bonheur et de bonne humeur.
Il faut presque se pincer pour y croire.
Comment critiquer quand on voit autant
de visages déformés par la joie ?
Pour clore ce petit tour
sur le modèle éducatif local,
Rien de tel qu'un petit spectacle.
Ça commence avec un jeune violoniste surdoué.
Tous sont maquillés.
Tous répètent une chorégraphie
apprise par cœur.
Ils se comportent comme
des adultes en miniature.
Guitaristes,
Danseurs virevoltant,
Chanteurs virtuoses.
Tous les gestes sont au millimètre.
Même le sourire semble forcé
pour ces petits pantins,
Censés incarner l'idéal nord coréen.
On peut imaginer les centaines
d'heures de travail,
Qui ont été nécessaires
pour arriver à ce résultat.
Pour finir en apothéose,
Rien de tel qu'une pianiste soliste
de seulement cinq ans,
Qui reproduit jusqu'au geste
d'un concertiste professionnel.
Les touristes français applaudissent la performance
et sont tous emballés.
Bravo !
Ça vous a plu ?
Oui !
Magnifique !
La visite du jardin d'enfants est maintenant terminée.
Nous remercions la directrice et les maîtresses.
On veut les bonus !
J'avais l'impression d'être revenu
au temps de mon enfance.
Où il y avait le maître qui nous emmenait,
Et on suivait et on ne se serait pas
permis de courir partout, de faire du bruit.
C'est vrai, ça me rappelait un petit peu
l'école dans les années 60, 70.
Un peu plus loin, sous le préau,
Une affiche retient notre attention.
Elle vient quelque peu modérer
l'enthousiasme ambiant.
Un guide vient traduire le slogan du poster.
Le général Kim Jung Il
est le meilleur du monde.
C'est enfants veulent devenir soldats
pour le général Kim Jung Il.
C'est ce genre de slogan qui rappelle
que l'on est bien dans une dictature.
Une dictature dans laquelle
l'armée tient un rôle majeur.
25% du budget de l'Etat lui est consacré.
C'est l'un des taux les plus élevés au monde.
En France, c'est juste dix fois moins.
En tout, il y aurait plus
d'un million de soldats,
Prêts à en découdre au moindre signe d'agression.
Une armée à l'ancienne,
Comme du temps de Staline,
Avec des fantassins par centaines de milliers,
Des femmes aussi,
Des tanks et des lance missiles.
Ainsi que des avions de chasse
complètement obsolètes.
Pourtant, l'armée nord coréenne
n'est pas si désuète.
Depuis 2006, Pyongyang possède l'arme atomique.
C'est justement pour cela que la Corée du Nord
fait si peur et n'est pas attaquée,
Même par les Américains.
Une situation, dont n'est pas peu fier Monsieur Jan,
L'un de nos guides.
Nous sommes maintenant très fiers d'avoir
une défense nationale très puissante.
Par exemple, nous sommes arrivés
à posséder des armes nucléaires.
Un pays en armes et secret,
c'est cela la Corée du Nord.
Et c'est vers l'une des régions
les plus secrètes du pays,
Que nous nous envolons maintenant.
Dans le Nord, près de la frontière russe.
Un vieux biréacteur nous attend sur le tarmac.
Il appartient à Air Koryo,
Qui a été inscrite sur la liste noire
des compagnies interdites de vol en Europe.
2h d'avion au dessus des montagnes,
En direction de la zone
où a vécu le père de Claude,
Il y a 90 ans.
C'est pour réaliser ce pèlerinage
que la Française est venue.
Nous arrivons maintenant près de la Sibérie
et le climat s'en ressent.
Normalement, les étrangers ne peuvent pas venir ici,
C'est une faveur exceptionnelle obtenue
suite à la demande de Claude.
Et à région spéciale, encadrement spécial.
3 nouveaux guides nous attendent.
Le moindre mouvement,
La moindre parole du groupe
de touristes seront épiés,
Et, si nécessaire, sanctionnés.
On se dirige maintenant vers le mont Paektu,
C'est le sommet du pays,
de 2750 mètres.
Mais après l'hiver,
Nous sommes les premiers visiteurs avec la voiture.
Cette fois-ci, on ne voit pas les traces des voitures.
Effectivement, la route est à peine praticable.
Mais très vite, la mauvaise nouvelle tombe.
On ne peut pas monter au mont Paektu.
C'est dangereux.
Vous voyez maintenant, si ça glisse, c'est fini !
Il reste encore 28km à faire sur de la neige gelée.
Impossible.
Claude est particulièrement déçue.
Claude, la route est bouchée là.
Oui, mais ça ne m'étonne pas.
Vu la quantité de neige qu'il y a,
Et ils n'ont pas d'engins ici,
ils ne mettent pas de sel.
Les véhicules ne sont pas équipés,
Ils ne mettent pas de chaînes
ou ils n'ont pas les pneus adaptés.
Et puis ils ne déneigent pas.
C'est sûr qu'il faut des sacré engins pour déneiger.
Jacqueline ne va pas se laisser faire.
Non mais on paye pour des prestations,
À la rigueur qu'on ne les ai pas,
Mais qu'elles soit remplacées
par d'autres équivalentes.
Même si ce n'est pas ce qui est écrit,
Même si ce n'est pas pour ce que j'ai signé, peu importe.
Mais arriver dans la neige pour être à l'hôtel,
On va demander un remboursement.
À défaut de montagne sacrée,
Les touristes tentent de visiter le village.
Ça à l'air désert.
On visite un village abandonné.
Ils sont où, les habitants ?
Je ne vois pas de fumée, je ne vois rien du tout.
Où sont les habitants ?
Nous n'en saurons pas plus.
Monsieur Jan, intervient tout de suite,
Il faut rentrer dans le bus.
Ce village n'est pas prévu au programme.
On rentre, on va aller déjeuner à l'hôtel.
Oui.
-Qu'elle heure est-il ?
-11h.
Plutôt que de rencontrer des habitants,
Les touristes vont avoir droit
à un nouveau matraquage,
Sur la vie du dictateur local.
Il fait froid et humide et dans le groupe,
On commence sérieusement à se lasser
de ces vacances sous contrôle.
Pour commencer, on efface les photos
prises pendant le trajet.
Une jeune femme en tenue de soldat les attend.
Bienvenue sur un site sacré,
Où Kim Il-Sung, l'homme fort du régime, serait né.
Un site où on ne fume pas.
Non, pas de cigarette.
On va d'abord visiter la maison natale,
Et puis après en descendant, on va voir.
La maison natale de Kim Il-Sung,
c'est censé être celle-ci.
Une relique qu'il faut forcément respecter.
On ne monte pas dessus.
On nous dit que c'est ici
que le dictateur est né,
Et qu'il a mené toute la guérilla
pour prendre le pouvoir.
Claude, qui connaît bien l'histoire du pays,
Refuse d'avaler cette propagande grossière.
Il est né de l'autre côté de la frontière ?
Oui, oui, parce qu'il s'était réfugié là-bas.
Il n'y a jamais eu de guérilla ici, en fait.
Mais bon...
C'est de la propagande ?
Oui, comme c'est écrit quelque part,
Que Kim Il-Sung a commencé
ces groupes de guérilla en 1920.
En 1920, il avait 8 ans.
Bon, il ne faut quand même pas
prendre les gens pour des idiots.
Pris pour des idiots,
Claude regrette très vite d'avoir
osé critiquer ouvertement le régime.
D'autant plus qu'autour de nous,
Des dizaines de caméras les espionnent.
Ils ont entendu ce qu'on a dit,
Crois-tu qu'il y a des micros
cachés partout ?
Ils vont traduire.
Et c'est donc en chuchotant
que son amie Jacqueline,
Se permet une comparaison peu orthodoxe
avec le système politique local.
On a l'impression de feuilleter
un beau livre de contes de fées,
Sauf que l'histoire ne finit pas bien,
Que l'ogre est toujours vivant.
Enfin tant qu'on ne se laissera pas manger,
tout va bien.
C'est une autre maison du même genre, là.
Henri, lui, ne se pose pas ce genre de questions.
Il adore tout et veut le montrer.
Il reste bouche bée quand la guide
se lance dans un chant patriotique,
Même sous la pluie.
Bravo !
Merci beaucoup, merci beaucoup. Très joli comme ça. Ça fait.
-C'est joli !
-C'est très joli.
Tout le monde chante bien, c'est fabuleux !
C'est le président Kim Il Sung
qui l'a composé.
Quant aux multiples statues du dictateur,
Il les salue sans même qu'on le lui demande.
L'encadrement Nord-Coréen n'en revient pas.
Je vais le refaire,
On va le refaire tous les deux.
Monsieur Hô est ravi du français qui
se comporte comme un vrai partisan du régime.
Un peu plus loin,
À quelques kilomètres,
Une autre statue en bronze,
au milieu de nulle part.
Encore à la gloire du dictateur.
Encore des fresques guerrières géantes.
Ce culte de la personnalité,
Claude n'en peut plus.
Mais là, ça dépasse tout.
À quel niveau ?
Au point de vue monumental, construction.
Puis ce culte omniprésent.
Il y a quand même
quelque chose d'important.
Henri, lui, n'est pas tout à fait d'accord.
Il y a tout de même
une démarche artistique.
Bien sûr, oui.
Mais c'est toujours le même style.
C'est comme quand elle chante,
toujours les mêmes mimes.
Il est évident que toutes
les perspectives sont étudiées.
Ça veut dire qu'on maîtrise tout.
Moi, ça me fait penser à
ce que voulez faire Hitler.
Oui.
Les plans de Berlin avec Speer,
c'est exactement la même chose.
C'est vrai que moi,
Je peux pas être fana
de ce style d'architecture.
Moi non plus mais...
Comparer le régime de Pyongyang à Hitler,
Claude se lâche vraiment.
Au moment de partir, le bus refuse de démarrer.
Heureusement, un groupe de militaires passe par-là.
Et c'est à une bonne dizaine
qu'ils se mettent pour pousser le véhicule.
Cette solidarité enthousiasme
un peu plus Henri.
Déjà plus d'une semaine que
nous sommes en Corée du Nord.
Et nous n'avons toujours pas pu
discuter avec des Nord-Coréens.
Mais ça va changer.
Nous allons sur la côte du pays,
Près de la mer du Japon.
Avec la promesse de dormir chez l'habitant
et de se promener librement.
Mais la réalité est tout autre.
Comme tous les rivages du pays,
la zone est classée ultrasensible.
La preuve, la route est entourée
de barbelés électrifiés.
Des barbelés pour se protéger,
Contre un éventuel débarquement
des Sud-Coréens ou des Américains.
Ce village, par exemple,
Il est interdit de le filmer.
Derrière ses palissades blanches,
Impossible de voir ce qu'il s'y cache.
Même pour Guillaume,
Qui organise ici des séjours
depuis une dizaine d'années,
C'en est trop.
Vraiment ils m'énervent.
Pourquoi ?
La photo que je prends,
je me fais engueuler.
Faut pas exagérer.
Si c'est comme ça,
Je ne programme jamais plus
rien dans cette région.
Même toi ils te mettent à l'amende.
Non mais là, je vais lui passer un savon,
De retour à Pyongyang.
Faut pas exagérer.
Je veux bien qu'on ait pas le droit
de prendre les installations de sécurité,
Mais prendre des paysages, faut quand même pas exagérer.
Comme d'habitude,
Monsieur Jan trouve une bonne raison
pour justifier ses consignes de sécurité.
Sur la plage et sur les
côtes c'est interdit,
De prendre des photos.
C'est partout une zone militaire.
Tant pis pour les touristes,
Qui vont quand même pouvoir
passer une nuit chez l'habitant.
Un privilège extrêmement rare
dans ce pays paranoïaque.
Sauf qu'ici, tout est faux.
Le village a été construit exprès
pour accueillir des étrangers de passage.
On a construit ce village,
Pour les étrangers,
Qui viennent visiter le mont Tchivo.
OK, donc c'est vraiment un beau village
avec les belles maisons.
Ils ont de la chance en fait.
Quant aux habitants,
Ils ont évidemment été triés sur le volet.
Cette femme, par exemple,
Fait partie de l'élite du régime.
La preuve, elle a eu l'honneur incroyable
de rencontrer Kim Il Sung, le leader du pays.
Un honneur qui n'est pas dû au hasard,
Car cette charmante dame,
Est l'une des meilleures mamans du pays,
Comme le rappelle Monsieur Hô.
Chez nous, de temps en temps,
On organise la conférence des mères,
On sélectionne des mères,
Qui élèvent bien leurs enfants,
Et puis qui travaillent bien.
Qui accordent de l'exploit
à l'édification socialiste.
Plutôt que de supporter un peu plus
la propagande du régime,
Les touristes vont tenter de s'évader.
La plage n'est pas loin.
L'occasion est trop belle
pour échapper aux contrôles des guides.
Pour la première fois,
Le vrai visage de la Corée du Nord
nous saute aux yeux.
C'est cette pauvreté qui assèche le pays
qu'il ne faut pas montrer.
Un groupe de femmes ramassent des algues
pleines de sable sur la plage.
Et les entassent dans des vieux sacs.
Ces algues, c'est la base de leur alimentation.
Mais nous sommes très vite rattrapés
par un membre de l'encadrement.
On peut aller voir les bateaux de pêche là-bas ?
Vous n'avez qu'à venir avec nous,
Jusqu'au bateau de pêche.
Allez ?
Non, c'est interdit.
Je n'ai aucune habilitation
pour aller plus loin sur cette route.
Et si vous allez là-bas seul et même avec moi,
Après ça...
Le geste a le mérite d'être clair.
L'homme risque sa vie,
Si le règlement n'est pas respecté.
C'est mon dernier mot.
Mais allez par là, vers l'intérieur,
C'est autorisé.
Par là, c'est un autre village.
Et cette fois-ci, c'est promis juré,
Toutes les photos sont autorisées.
À l'entrée, un plan un peu étrange.
L'architecture se veut typique du style coréen.
On retrouve le moral parmi les touristes.
C'est chouette, j'adore.
J'ai fait plein de photos ce matin.
C'est beau et propre.
Ils ont même le droit à une petite
démonstration de la cuisine traditionnelle locale.
Mais encore une fois, tout est sous contrôle
et parfaitement faux.
Personne ne vit ici.
Les vacanciers ne croiseront aucun Coréen,
Hormis quelques employés qui n'ont
pas le droit de leur parler.
Nous trouvons un petit passage
qui permet d'aller dehors,
Mais c'est peine perdue,
Il y a toujours quelqu'un pour s'interposer.
On va pouvoir se promener dehors, là ?
Aller au marché.
Qu'à cela ne tienne,
Nous essayons de convaincre
les guides d'aller dehors.
Pour Monsieur Hô, c'est hors de question.
Bon, moi, je vais me promener dehors dans la rue
et je reviens après.
Oh non, ensemble, la porte est fermée maintenant.
Pourquoi c'est fermé ?
Je peux passer par là, c'est ouvert.
J'ai vu, il y a un petit passage.
Non, ça...
C'est pas possible ?
On ne donne pas la permission.
Monsieur Jan, Monsieur Oh a dit que je pouvais
aller me promener dehors,
Et qu'après je revenais ici dans 10 minutes.
C'est pas possible !
Je vais aller à la librairie alors.
Ce n'est pas possible !
Je connais ton truc !
J'ai essayé quand même.
Notre guide Jan ne se laisse pas berner.
Il connaît les règles et risque gros.
Pas d'images de la vraie vie.
Ce faux village est comme le reste du pays,
Une prison d'où l'on ne sort pas si facilement.
Les lourdes portes en bois massif
restent closes sur tous ces Nord-Coréens,
Qui ne peuvent s'échapper de la
dernière grande dictature de la planète.
Un régime qui vient encore d'être condamné
par la communauté internationale.